things you didn't know about breath of
the wild still running strong since you
all enjoyed the musical secrets of
breath of the wild last time we'll dive
a little bit more into the music again
so it's time to crank up that audio if
you continue to enjoy this series let us
know with the like alright here we go
hajime wakai the sound designer for
breath of the wild had a tough time
initially realizing the music of the
game specifically the overworld music
one of the first things he tried out was
twilight princess's hyrule field theme
as you were exploring
[Music]
but because of the different tone of
breath of the wild he felt like this was
too intense for players in a quote he
said the music would be all stirring and
dramatic but then the player would think
hold on a minute all i did was throw
away a mushroom
he also considered several different
instruments during his testing before
finally deciding on the piano but one
thing he considered before that decision
that was a little bit weird was the
dulcimer
[Music]
i don't know about that chief
a comment during the last video noted
that with this quest with tembo the zora
kid you give him five hot-footed frogs
which he uses to sell while his mom is
away when you give him the frogs in
every language he counts like normal one
through five
[Music]
but in german specifically he counts
them in solfege do re mi fa soul
[Music]
sounds like the german translators
understood nintendo's easter egg a
little bit better another pointed out
that in the zora domain some zora npcs
are based on things that are used in
sheet music such as baz for bass clef
[Music]
trello for treble clef clef 4 referring
to clefs in general
key referring to key and key signatures
and la flat referring to the flat symbol
to lower a note's pitch
have you heard these sounds before
they might sound vaguely familiar
because these are sounds that play in
direct response to you landing an attack
on an enemy first the main combat theme
is split into three parts roughly 30
seconds each the first intro part sounds
like this
[Music]
and is titled field battle easy when
striking an enemy it will react and use
these audio files labeled as easy using
these subtle notes
when it transitions to this section this
is called field battle middle
and hits on an enemy now will react with
two or three note piano trills
then it will transition into this grand
section called field battle hard
it will react with more recognizable
clacks
hoots
and symbols
now that you know let's hear in action
in an example
[Music]
now that you know you can't unhear it
this also happens when you're up against
the guardian stalker so listen carefully
the next time you're up against one did
you know that the gerudo guards are
organized by rank with the color that
they wear blue are the lowest ranked
squads green are higher ranked squads
and red denotes the squad leader and
captain of them all teak blue guards are
seen virtually everywhere but you can
see higher ranked green guards protect
more high value targets such as the
important northern ice house and
bouleara of course protecting riju this
is a pretty old secret that some players
still haven't caught but if you listen
closely to the ambient music of each
divine beast you can actually hear a
strange secret message
did you hear it it goes a little bit
something like this
[Music]
this is actually real morse code
spelling out sos or a cry for help
[Music]
funny thing is in stereo audio this
message only plays in one ear the right
side for the boys the rook and rivali
and only on the left side for the girls
mifa and urbosa this is likely a message
left by the four champions before they
die to calamity ganon which makes his
music all the more eerie every time you
listen to it additionally there's a
second message playing in the opposite
ear
fans speculate it spells sad which is
short for search and destroy but from my
personal research it's clearly not this
message there's an article i'll link
below listing all the possibilities of
what this message could mean but it's
something we may never know
everyone's seen a snowball and they're
usually around in situations where they
roll down a hill until they break or are
too heavy and can't be pushed anymore
but by using magnesis on certain
equipment to push the snowball even more
you can create a snowball to its maximum
size
there are so many hidden references to
past zelda music behind breath of the
wild soundtrack that they would consume
an entire video or two to cover
individually but some of my personal
favorite ones are behind the temple of
times theme
[Music]
and ocarina of times house theme hidden
behind pando and selmy's cabin music
[Music]
there are countless other examples of
this kind of secret hidden within the
music
hyrule castle's music has multiple
secrets built in as well but my favorite
one is it's most frightening let's first
hear a link to the past original sound
effects for being low on health
and now here's the interior hyrule
castle theme you might hear something
similar
[Music]
you can hear it simulating a heartbeat
on the organ behind zelda's lullaby but
what's more sinister is what happens
next
[Music]
the heartbeat speeds up then flatlines
this chilling secret is likely pointing
to zelda being on our last legs holding
calamity ganon back alone guardians have
a hidden rule you might have
accidentally run into if you hide around
a corner and they lose track of you
sneaking up on them and hitting them
will trigger them to fire by reflex to
where they saw you last it's not super
practical but by them putting an enemy
in that line of sight this will let link
use the guardian like a stationary
machine gun turret and boy does it hurt
did you know that you could play catch
with a lazalfos they often throw their
weapon at link as a last resort tactic
when they're lower on hp
and if you pick up the weapon off the
ground fast enough they'll wait for you
to toss it back at them take the day off
play some catch with your lasalfo son
[Music]
one secret that's much harder to spot is
in kakariko village's theme there's one
extremely subtle nod to the original
kakariko theme song hidden in the notes
you probably missed hajimewakai said
that the secret wasn't found by players
initially and he had to hint at us to
find it during an interview
[Music]
[Applause]
didn't hear it well here's some
background notes to help point them out
[Music]
it's the latter half of the beginning
part of the original kakariko theme song
using a glockenspiel
[Music]
what's more interesting though is this
is a second subtle nod to ocarina times
version where there's a glockage peel
used in that song as well
[Music]
what was your favorite thing you learned
this time let us know in the comments
below we also still have an ongoing
playlist with all the latest breath of
the wild content still coming so keep it
here on gamespot
[Music]
you